المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
فان القوات الروسيه شنت هجوما جديدا على
ورش لصناعه القوارب المسيره في اوديسا
وايلي تشيفسكا الجنوبيه اوكرانيا وقال
كوناشينغوف عند القوات الروسيه صدت 16
هجوما اوكرانيا في محور الشرقيه البلاد
ورجوع
واصلت القوات الروسيه الليله الماضيه شان
ضربات الانتقاميه باسلحه بحريه وجويه
عاليه الدقه على ورش لانتاج القوارب
المسيره ومستودعات لتخزينها في مدينتي
اوديسا وايلي تشيفيسك وفي مدينه تم تدمير
مرافق البنيه التحتيه للوقود ومستودعات
الذخيره للقوات الاوكرانيه تم تحقيق جميع
الاهداف بنجاح
من جهاته قال البيت الابيض ان الولايات
المتحده شاهدت اشارات على ان روسيا تستعد
لمهاجمه سفن مدنيه تحمل الحبوب في البحر
الاسود وعبر المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
اوليفيا دالتون في احاطه غير مصوره عن قلق
واشنطن من الهجمات الروسيه على الموانئ
الاوكرانيه